welcome to the show everybody a few
different things to talk about today and
first of all I hope you've had a blessed
Veterans Day so far thank you for all
those who have served and it's
unfortunate that on a day to celebrate
courage the courage of those who serve
we have to begin by talking about
cowardice the cowardice of our
disgraceful media cowardice evidenced in
so many ways but especially now in its
silence surrounding the ABC Jeffrey
Epstein scandal you know I I remarked
last week about the irony and hypocrisy
of the fact that ABC and CBS colluded to
fire a whistleblower so after all this
time the media has spent talking about
protecting whistleblowers and talking
about the evils of collusion then they
would turn around and collude to fire a
whistleblower so you can't
the irony can't be lost on you after
someone leaked the tape of an ABC
reporter revealing how ABC covered for
Epstein and Spike the story about a
serial sex abuse and sex trafficking ABC
then as we talked about last week they
went on a mission to track that person
down and punish them eventually they
found the person or they thought they
did working now at CBS and CBS fired her
on behalf of their rival for the crime
of blowing the whistle on corruption
within ABC but it gets worse it got much
worse for ABC and CBS at the end of last
week on Friday turns out the woman they
fired for being a whistleblower wasn't
even a whistleblower they colluded
against a whistleblower but ended up
punishing an innocent woman so they they
tried to collude to fire whistleblower
but they failed and it gets even worse
than that because we find this out from
an interview with the woman who was
wrongfully terminated the innocent woman
who was blamed for being a whistleblower
but isn't we find this out in an
interview interview she did with megyn
kelly megyn kelly scooped the entire
mainstream media even
she'd been fired by a mainstream media
outlet she came in and showed them what
real reporting and and real journalism
looks like embarrassing them even more
in the process and it's a great
interview by the way so let's let's take
a look at some of this this is the
woman's name is Ashley Bianco former ABC
producer and here she is with Megan
Kelly explaining what really happened
with respect to the now infamous tape
Ashley thank you for joining me
did you leak the tape I did not not to
anyone
know it at any time no did you make a
clip of the moment I did but I saved it
I saved it in the internal system so
what was your job at ABC I was a crash
producer okay so a producer yeah and you
were in the control room when Amy made
those comments
I wasn't in the control room but I was I
was watching the comments while I was at
my desk and I had seen what she was
saying and I went to my manager and I
said you know do you see what she's
saying does she know that she's on a hot
mic the assistant said to us that the
Amy knew she was on a mic and that she
knew she was being broadcasted to all
the affiliates right so this is a moment
where she's off the air she's doing
taped promos but she has a mic on and
people can see and hear her yeah so what
made you what did you do you clip the
moment you sort of mark the moment in
the system yeah I just cooked it off I
essentially marked it in the system I
never left the system we do it all the
time did you tell the manager that you
had clipped it I did not did you think
it was newsworthy what she was saying
everyone in the office was freaked out
by what she was saying and everyone was
was watching it so their purpose for
clipping it was what to watch it back
later yeah watch it back later
um you know I I did it just for office
gossip you know mm-hmm was there any
intention to embarrass her no not at all
or ABC no I would never was this the
first time you had ever clipped a
segment of an anchor off-mike no I mean
we do it all the time
you know I'm part of my job is I'm like
a video editor you know I clip off
moments all the time I put together you
know funny anchor reels
of you know them off-camera doing funny
stuff to use later in the show did you
go back and watch it later I didn't know
I didn't even anything about after that
day okay so her crime is that she saw
the tape and she clipped it which is
that's her job to clip tape never showed
it to anybody never sent it to anyone
I wasn't trying to embarrass the
reporter wasn't trying to embarrass ABC
as much as ABC deserves to be
embarrassed and eventually embarrassed
itself in fact she said that she never
even heard of Project Veritas and I
think that was actually an interesting
moment where she talks about about that
let's let's let's watch that so was that
the last you had to do with that clip
yeah I didn't touch it and do anything
else with that you never went back to it
I never went back to it you didn't
download it you didn't email it you
didn't transfer that file in any way no
not at all I didn't touch it after that
it stayed in the system I hadn't even
heard of Project Veritas until this you
know what's interesting about that she
says that she never thought about the
clip or looked at it again she said that
she'd never heard of Project Veritas now
I believe her on that I believe that she
never heard of project Veritas but that
alone let's focus on that for a second
that just reveals what kind of bubble
these media companies are keeping their
employees in I mean the woman is a
producer for a major news network and
she looks at clips and things for her
job and she doesn't even know about the
existence of Project Veritas or James
O'Keefe which however you might feel
about James O'Keefe and his operation
they've made a lot of news over the
years so having never heard of them is
pretty stunning for someone and that
would be like someone at Fox News a
producer at Fox News who had never heard
of Media Matters now I'm not comparing
Media Matters to Project Veritas like
Project Veritas is a legitimate
organization Media Matters is just a
just a bunch of
smear artists but the point is it's it's
a similar in terms of the bubble you
would have to be in it that that is
pretty incredible but not the point of
the the interview just worth remarking
on I think
and then Ashley Bianco starts talking
about what happened when she was fired
and she describes the scene how CBS
handled it and we'll get to that clip in
a moment but first a word from light
stream you know the holidays are
approaching and you may be thinking
about how you're gonna save some extra
money I've got a way that you could save
money that maybe you haven't thought of
yet consolidate your high interest
credit card balances to a lower rate and
you can save that way with light Stream
generate as low as five point nine five
percent APR with Auto pay which is much
lower than the national average interest
rate of twenty percent APR so that's
actually an understatement to say it's
lower you're talking about five point
nine five verse twenty percent plus your
rate is fixed so as the rates continue
to rise your low rate will not budge and
you get that peace of mind also that's
stability and knowing that the rate
isn't going to rise for you just for my
listeners apply now to get a special
interest rate discount the only way to
get this discount is to go to light
stream comm slash Walsh lig HT s TR e km
comm slash Walsh that's light stream
comm slash Walsh subject to credit
approval rates include point five
percent auto pay discount terms and
conditions apply and offers are subject
to change without notice visit like
stream comm slash Walsh for more
information ok back to the interview
with the falsely accused a Chicago
here's her describing her own firing by
CBS and then in the fall you decided to
leave ABC to go where to CBS and I only
left purely because CBS had offered me a
good contract and so I you know I I left
and I was just really excited to start a
new job and and so this week you're
sitting at CBS doing your job yeah and
and what happens with Project Veritas
they released the video you know and I
was shocked but I didn't think anything
of it how many days had you been
yes my four days you know and I yeah you
bagged I pleaded I didn't know what I
had done wrong and I just you know I
didn't I wasn't even given the
professional courtesy to defend myself
you know I didn't know what I had been
accused of it was you know humiliating I
was devastated
have you ever spoken to James O'Keefe of
Project Veritas no never I didn't even
know who he was until this week and
hadn't communicated with anybody who
works there in any way shape or form
no yeah I've never communicate with
anyone over there what was your reaction
when you found out ABC news had called
CBS devastated I mean like I'll never
get a job anywhere oh it was devastating
so they brought this woman over from ABC
they offered her a contract
four days after she starts they'd fire
her because of what ABC accused her of
and according to her and they never gave
her a chance to explain herself never
gave her a chance to defend herself she
didn't even understand what she'd done
wrong and all of this simply because she
was exposed to the clip of the reporter
this is like this is like some Martin
Scorsese mob movie type of stuff a B a B
C is just offing the witnesses that's
what's happening here it's really
incredible meanwhile the actual person
who did leaked the tape to Project
Veritas is still in the company still
working not for CBS but for a B C and
they haven't been found yet they're
still there that person the real
whistleblower came out well didn't come
out publicly but published something
anonymously with Project Veritas just to
try to I guess realizing that someone
else is being framed for the for the
deed and what they published it's worth
going and checking out what they had to
say but it says in part I came forward
with this information bearing no motives
other than to have this information
public I did not and do not seek any
personal gain from this information
whether it be financial or otherwise and
will always decline when I became aware
of this moment I had the same reaction
as many of you did anger confusion and
sadness
not about petty political koala orals
and only hope for the best and all of us
goes on a little bit later I sit here
with all of you in complete shock I like
many are at a loss for words on how this
has been handled instead of addressing
this head-on like the company has in the
past it has spun into a mission of seek
and destroy innocent people that have
absolutely nothing to do with this are
being hunted down as if we're all sport
I challenge all of you to actually look
inwards and remember why this company
engages in journalism we all hold the
First Amendment at the foundation of
this company of this company yet forget
its history its purpose and its
reasoning for even coming into existence
to begin with how lost we are yearning
to be found I went to project project
Veritas for the sole reason that any
other media outlet would have probably
shelved this as well I think all of them
and James for seeking the truth so
that's the real whistleblower I guess
the the hunt is still on by ABC they're
still trying to track this person down
by the way in case you were wondering
the the rest of media has continued
their blackout of this story one of the
most blatant blackouts of a story that I
can think of aside from the yearly
blackout that they do of the March for
Life every year when there are 500,000
people walking you know marching down
the street in Washington DC literally
walking through the the front yard of
these people and and it gets hardly any
coverage by the media so it's it's sort
of on that level in terms of of everyone
in the media being on the same page that
we're not going to talk about this thing
brian Stelter
a CNN's media reporter did his show on
on CNN yesterday it's a weekly show that
he does on Sundays and it's a show about
the media a show all about covering
media stories what did he have to say
about this nothing he said absolutely
nothing about it a show about media and
it doesn't mention the biggest story in
media much is the biggest story of media
this week but the biggest story of media
in the
several years CNN advertises Stelter
show ironically named reliable sources
advertises it as a show that quote
examines the media world telling the
story behind the story and a show that
tells us how the news gets made well
here's a story behind the story talk
about a story behind the story here's
something showing how the news gets made
or doesn't get made in this case and we
have tape of it
we have tape of a reporter confessing to
all of this and Stelter just ignores it
this is really like it would be as if
CNN's weather reporter ignored a cat5
hurricane bearing down on Florida
imagine if there was an hour-long show
about the weather on CNN and it's it
didn't even mention the hurricane they
made no mention of it it wasn't even
like they buried it it was just they
pretended it wasn't happening and this
shows again what fake news really
consists of and how it works what media
bias really means because the way people
talk about the media that the critics of
the media the way that they or I should
say we often talk about the media and
being media bias it's as if we're saying
that the media literally invents stories
out of whole cloth well not literally
invent stories of all cloth I mean no
one thinks that they're actually
building a story out of cloth but anyway
we talk about it as as if we're saying
that the media is just making up stories
off the top of their head and reporting
it now
that might happen sometimes or something
close to that might happen sometimes but
that's not generally the way media bias
and fake news works and it's important
for us to realize this so we know what
we're dealing with in reality the bias
is much more insidious and more and it's
more insidious because it's less glaring
though this time it's pretty damned
glaring but the real bias the the most
damaging kind of bias is in how
they choose which stories to ignore so
that's how you know if they're really
worried about something not because
they're making up store but if they just
ignore it and pretend it's not happening
and the good
for them is when they do that they can
always turn around and say Oh what do
you mean this isn't fake news we didn't
you know we didn't make anything up
right you're just you're you're
pretending it's not happening which is
just as bad so brian Stelter z' media
show we could say his media show on
Sunday it was all fake news and not
because the things he was talking about
weren't true although I'm sure a lot of
it wasn't but it's a media show and the
the implication is OK viewer here's all
the important stuff happening in media
didn't mention this so what you're
saying without saying it is this thing
over here didn't happen that's fake news
speaking of fake news here's the
fact-checking site PolitiFact you know
these fact check any time a site
advertises itself as a fact checker
that's when you know that it probably
does basically the opposite of that
PolitiFact is debunking what they say is
a false claim and and here's the the
screenshot it says a trump ad said
Democratic presidential candidates
support giving illegal immigrants free
health care at our expense we rated that
mostly false now a Florida GOP leader
made a similar statement it is still
mostly false okay
mostly false well let's go and look at
the tape raise your hand if covered if
your government plan would provide
coverage for undocumented immigrants and
everybody's hands go up
now what PolitiFact tries to do here the
move they pull is to say that well yeah
the candidates said they would provide
health care to illegals but they never
said it would be free see that wasn't
stipulated and and it wasn't the word
free did not appear in that question
when the moderator said would you give
health care to undocumented immigrants
it wasn't said free health care but all
of these candidates support some version
of free health care all of them knew
so the free part is implied I mean does
anyone have any doubt that if you asked
any of these candidates whether a poor
illegal immigrant with no money but
would should still get coverage does
anyone have any doubt that they would
all say yes so they don't need to say
free but this is once again it's it's
the lie by omission
PolitiFact says well they never said
free yeah but you're leaving out the
fact that that is implied when Democrats
are talking about health care the free
part is implied okay here are some poll
results that I'm seeing shared around
social media that are I think pretty
interesting here's the graphic from pew
the question from pew is can couples who
are living together but not married
raise children just as well as married
couples and sixty percent of Americans
say yes overall almost half of
Protestants over half of Catholics
almost 80 percent of religiously
unaffiliated all of them say sure you
know no need to be married to raise kids
now technically there is a way to
understand this question that could
justify those results the question was
can not is likely to so technically you
could say well what if you've got an
abusive alcoholic married couple
compared to sober non-abusive unmarried
parents couldn't the unmarried ones in
that scenario do a better job of
parenting or at least as good a job and
sure but but that's so if the question
is can is it logically possible well
yeah it's logically possible but that's
it's not really what the question seems
to imply it seems to imply that the 60%
of Americans there isn't much of a
difference between married and unmarried
couples when it comes to their abilities
to to raise kids and that is just
completely foolish and also pretty
concerning
when you consider that a certain portion
of the people answering that question or
who have that opinion haven't had kids
yet themselves and so what they're
revealing is that now you know if I ever
have kids I don't see any reason why I
have to be married first one of the if I
could just explain briefly for anyone
who's confused on this one of the most
important things that you can give to a
child one of the most essential needs of
a child besides the basics of food water
clothing shelter all that but one of the
most essential deeper human needs of the
child is security and I'm not just
talking about physical security although
there's that but also emotional
spiritual psychological security that
knowledge that feeling that he's in a
stable environment where both parents
are committed to each other and to the
family and they aren't going to leave
they aren't going to give up they're
gonna bad and they are going to cut and
run when you aren't married and you're
raising kids
you simply cannot provide that kind of
security to the child which is something
the child needs in fact you are refusing
to provide it you are you are clearly
refusing it in principle you're saying
to the kid even if you're not saying it
out loud the implication is what you're
saying is yeah I could leave any time
that's why I'm not getting married
because I want to have the ability to
leave and maybe a child at a very young
age can't put two and two together on
that doesn't really understand what
marriage is versus not marriage but as a
child gets older they're going to put
that together and realize that the only
reason you're not getting married is
because you want to have the option of
leaving and that is very traumatic for a
child just just the possibility of that
I can remember as a kid when I first my
parents were married but and growing up
you know as a very young child before I
went to school even the idea of parents
leaving and marriages falling apart just
died it never occurred to me I didn't
no that was a thing I never even thought
of it but then as I go to school and
this was in the in the you know early
90s so it was part of the divorce boom
the divorce boom was still was still
very much in effect has never quite gone
away though it's died down a little bit
and and I remember going to school and
with all these and I start meeting all
these kids with divorced parents and
that was I I can very I can remember
distinctly when that realization dawned
on me that that was even an option that
that was even a thing that could happen
and that's really difficult for child so
I remember going home to my mom and and
bringing this up to her and saying you
know I'm worried that you and dad are
gonna are you dad gonna get divorced and
I was saying that not because of things
I'd seen in the home but just because of
things I heard from my friends at school
and I remember she sat me down I
remember it distinctly
she sat me down and said you know your
dad and I will never leave each other we
will never get divorced you never have
to worry about that never and she was
right and I believed her but being able
to believe her if she had tried to say
that to me if she had tried to sit me
down and say look your dad and I we're
never gonna leave each other we're in
this for the long haul well you know
we're all together we're a family if she
had tried to give me that speech and
they weren't even married then I think
it'd be very difficult for me to believe
it but I did believe it and being able
to believe it was really important for
me I think for my development as a child
to just know that I am that I'm safe
when I go home and that this thing we've
got going on in the house it's not gonna
fall apart and you got to be able to
give that to kit now of course there are
we're talking about divorce
so there are children who think they
have that that kind of security and then
find out they don't but the ideal here
the point
is that we should be giving that to a
child which means getting married and
and then importantly actually staying
married okay let's go to emails Matt
well show at gmail.com Matt well show at
gmail.com actually before we get to
emails I did have one other thing to say
the the important issue that I don't
want to gloss over the popeyes chicken
sandwich that everyone's been talking
about I finally I finally had a chance
to try it and I'll tell you the truth
this popeyes chicken sandwich that is
it's got the whole the whole world's
talking about it
biggest thing going on in the world and
I finally tried it I was very skeptical
as I was eating it I'll be honest with
you I started to cry I was crying
because I knew that the truth that
Popeyes had declared war on chick-fil-a
they were going for chick-fil-a's throne
and with this sandwich they had
succeeded they had crowned themselves
king of the chicken sandwich I didn't
think they'd be able to do it but they
did this is like the stuff of epic
poetry it was it was tragic so as I'm
eating it and as a big chick-fil-a fan
myself as I'm eating it I sense the
tragedy of it yet it's also beautiful
because as one King Falls another takes
its place and I thought about that and I
wept and everybody at Popeyes was
staring at me and then someone came up
and stabbed me in the chest because well
it's Popeyes that's what happens there
if you can overlook that part of it so
what I'll say is the experience of
eating at Popeyes is is well it's it in
some ways more exciting than eating a
chick-fil-a you never know what's gonna
happen at a Popeye's but it's not always
as pleasant so I think that chick-fil-a
still has the 1up in terms of customer
service especially customer service I
don't even think what happens at Popeyes
I don't think you can call that customer
service you just walk in they
Galilei is one of those places where
they sneer at you for even walking in
the door and then you just throw the
food at you yeah what do you want you
want chicken here take it
get out of here that's what Popeyes does
which I kind of appreciate it because
it's honest and it's yeah hey we don't
forget about all the pleasantries I
don't need any of that my pleasure you
know they're not gonna they're not gonna
do that for you but when it comes down
to the food it's you I think there's no
denying that the popeyes chicken
sandwich is just better it just is all
right let's go to emails then from Jacob
says hi I'm Adam big fan of the show and
congrats for your new mug yes my new mug
right here thank you thank you thank you
for noticing it um I really enjoyed your
piece of music you played last week I
listen to it over and over and was
deeply inspired and found it spiritually
uplifting I recently argued with a
friend regarding discrimination of the
basis of religion I have difficulties
understanding why it's wrong unlike race
which one is born with religion is a set
of viewpoints and moral values that a
man can accept or reject so why is it at
all wrong to discriminate if I believe
that one that one's beliefs are bigoted
or wrong I was thinking maybe there's a
distinction between kids who are raised
with a certain religion and didn't
choose it to adults who can decide
themselves what do you think psi married
two years ago we're now expecting twins
perhaps you can share a good piece of
advice for raising twins PPSS i think
you should be PPS anyway why are you
remove why have you removed from Twitter
from your Twitter but Twitter bio the
theocratic fascist title thanks for
reading well hi Jacob asked for your
third question I took it I took the
theocratic fascist thing down for a time
because I thought it was important for
me to emphasize my preferred pronouns
which are we us our but it's back on
there now so have no fear as for your
second question about twins
congratulations first of all what is my
advice my advice on on raising twins is
well here's what I would say what you
want to do generally is to make the
right parenting decisions
as opposed to making the wrong decisions
so let me try to explain it what if
you're confused when you're faced with a
parental situation or decision basically
what you're gonna say to yourself is
what's the right thing to do and then
you're gonna do that so you may be
tempted sometimes to do the wrong thing
but what I would recommend is don't do
that thing the wrong one do the right
one
and anyway I'm writing a parenting
advice book which I sort of flesh this
out in more detail because I know it can
be a little overwhelming at times as for
your first question but discrimination
based on religion it depends on what
kind of discrimination you're talking
about you as a private citizen I agree
have every right to discriminate against
me based on the fact that I'm Catholic
so you can do that you horrible big it
if you want to if you don't want to
associate with me if you don't want to
consort with the likes of me that's fine
no that's your right until I am crowned
theocratic fashions in which case you'll
be executed but until that moment you
have every right to do it discrimination
becomes a constitutional issue or it
should only become a constitutional
issue when it's the state doing it and
so why can't the state discriminate
based on religion well because you're
right to believe what you believe is
essential it is integral that's what
freedom of religion really protects
that's why it's folded into the First
Amendment it protects your right to
believe what you believe and to say what
you believe and and those two rights are
fundamental to us as human beings you
say that religion is a choice well I
don't in a sense yes but in another
sense no because is it really a choice
to believe something I would argue that
it's it's kind of not really a choice to
believe because you either believe
something or you don't so what you can't
do is just get up one day and decide
that okay I'm gonna believe
such-and-such
or get up and decide oh I believe this I
believe this thing yesterday I'm not
gonna believe it anymore
so if when we talk about choice of what
we mean is that you know the ability to
just switch courses and and your walk in
that direction and you choose the walk
to walk another direction if we're
talking about that sort of choice then
in a sense no religion and belief is not
a choice because you either believe it
or you don't you can make choices that
eventually lead you to certain
conclusions that you hadn't arrived at
before and can you can make a series of
choices that lead you in the direction
of developing a new belief system or
losing a belief system that you had
before you can choose to listen to
someone as they're explaining their
belief system and you could choose to
take that seriously and consider what
they believe so you can make all those
choices but what you can't do is just at
the at the drop of a hat snapping your
fingers choose to believe something or
to not believe something and that again
is why it's so important that we have
this freedom because whatever you think
about religion whether it doesn't matter
for the for the government to come in
and say you can't believe that well it's
not only is that tyranny but it's it
would be impossible to follow that or
for the government to come and say you
have to believe this like further
government to impose a state religion
and say hey if you live here you have to
believe this religion what do you mean
have to believe it what if I don't what
if I can't
what if I just don't believe it so
that's um those are things to keep in
mind
but the most important thing is when
we're talking about freedom of religion
even if you're not a religious person I
don't know if you are or not but even if
you're not a religious person you should
still take freedom of religion seriously
and it's still important to you because
it's not just religion per se that it's
protecting its your right to believe
things and you have your own belief
system whatever it happens to be and so
the freedom of religion protects that
also First Amendment protects that
broadly speaking ok let's go to Travis
says thoroughly enjoyed your banjo song
it was just the right length not too
long not too short
when will you be recording your album
are we all required to listen to your
music to avoid being put to death what
would happen if some [ __ ] started
booing you while you were onstage
Travis listening to my musical pieces of
course won't be enough you'll need to
show an appropriate level of emotional
investment I need to see the tears
welling up in the eyes I need to feel
your enthusiasm for my music and anyone
who fails to show that enthusiasm will
be strangled to death with one of my
banjo strings or cords or whatever
they're called finally let's see this is
from I got a couple good ones well we'll
do this one and then we'll show you the
next one from our says from Mark says
hello Matt you've been writing about
airplane etiquette for a while and this
last suggestion is a front to all window
seat dwellers everyone knows that the
person who is in the window seat has all
power and authority regarding the window
if I wanted up if I want it up and you
want it down well that's unfortunate for
you aisle sinner I want to be able to
stretch my leg and have quicker access
to my bag and getting out that human to
brachot with wings I may ask for your
preference but I am under no obligation
you can give me your request but I have
sole and absolute veto authority over
that request with no option for it to be
overturned yes mark refers to a tweet
that I sent about airplane etiquette
which has been a focus of mine recently
as a frequent flyer myself the lack of
etiquette on planes has really taken a
toll on me physically emotionally
spiritually
and so here's my point in a typical
seating arrangement on a plane assuming
it's a medium to large-sized plane in
your and you're not in first class then
you're gonna be sitting in a row
probably with three seats window middle
aisle right here's the problem I like to
sit in the aisle seat as I have
discussed and I won't go into the trials
and tribulations that I've gone through
and just protecting my right to that
aisle seat but the point is that that's
where I like to sit because it gives me
access to the aisle gives me a little
more legroom
it's the least claustrophobic option of
all the claustrophobic options but the
problem is that I also like to be able
to look out the window at my leisure
because look first of all we're 35,000
feet in the air I think it's really sad
that you're flying 500 miles an hour
35,000 feet there we're over the clouds
and what's the first thing that everyone
does as soon as the plane takes off they
just put the window down are you really
you can't appreciate you don't want to
look out and see that beautiful view
you're in the sky flying and you're so
jaded to all of it that you just put the
window shade down and you don't even
want to look out the window what if we
were what if we were on a what if this
is 20 years in the future that we we're
doing tourist flights to the moon and
Mars are you gonna go to Mars and have
the window shade down the whole time
it's crazy and also at the same time I
like to look out the window so that I
can alert the pilot if we're about to
crash because he might need my help and
so I want to keep an eye on things and
if it looks like something's going down
I want to be able to go tell him so the
problem is that the person the window
seat usually puts the shade down without
consulting anyone else in the row as if
they own the window as if it's their
decision to make this is immoral
unethical undemocratic it puts lives at
risk potentially and my point is and I
said I said on Twitter and it provoked a
backlash from all these window hogs but
just because you're sitting in the
window seat you don't own the window
show me on your ticket you you got a
you're flying United or whatever your
sit says you're sitting in the window
seat show
be on the ticket where it says that you
control the window show me that you
can't you don't control the window that
window is controlled by the community
that is a communal window and so if you
want to put the shade down you need to
consult with the RO this is America damn
it this is not North Korea now obviously
that said the person in the middle seat
has no rights and is not really human
the middle seat person is filth and scum
they are burden you automatically hate
them the moment they sit down and they
deserve it they have no right to be
there everyone knows this so when I say
that you have to consult with the other
people I'm saying there's really only
one the person in the middle is not a
person so you have to consult with the
aisle person and there has to be an
agreement if there's no agreement then
the window stays up default position and
that's probably how it was when you got
on the plane and that's all that you
know that's that's just that's my point
it's it's a really it's a it's this is
not just courtesy this is about this is
about standing for American values and
the American ideal in our founding
fathers did not put all their
sweat and tears into founding this great
nation just so that one person could sit
in the window-seat
and decide if the shade goes up or down
that is not what they had in mind
amen right god bless america and thanks
everyone for watching thank you for
listening
Godspeed the Matt Walsh show is produced
by Sean Hampton executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Sterling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Donovan Fowler audio mixer Mike
Cora Mena the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 Don jr. destroys the view even more
Democrats Amala presidential run nikki
Haley blows the whistle on White House
sabotage and surveys show conservatives
are hotter and more dateable than
liberals check it out on the Michael
Noel's show